how's it going rest mining is being
routed bad today I have with me my
lovely girlfriend we're gonna play some
Anisha it's Valentine's Day so what
better way to spend it than play amnesia
alone in the dark dark castle evil
secrets that sounds it didn't even
spelled it is he's doing this by is it
doing this spelling on purpose the dag
yeah he has to do yeah man no one can do
that bad spelling I don't think like a
dish done is that cute so it's an
upside-down Sun can't you tell yes it is
not the thing is they can't see itself
they can't be all like Oh pip eyes right
lucky for you I'm cold snap Who am I
where am I
I must escape alright let's ship
beautiful ham thing look at this we we
it's yummy
all right and we should loot the drawers
over there I'm controlling I don't know
what I'm good look at the joist on the
wrong side all right
let's get out of here I don't like this
I miss a chair head up at it laughter oh
you're talking to me
what do you say boys box talking to me
who are you
what am i why do I haven't talked into a
box but can you move oh I don't know I
done that
hahaha okay awesome song box yeah
oh snap oh snap oh snap
no don't go that yeah yeah I don't mean
to do it
take this with me us Go Go is coming bow
it's your father
boxes are singing in it I know it's
carpet you can't just come see there
don't we have the left piggy what did it
do to you
like a pomp they are yeah yeah not
really yeah they were too pumped and
they ended up like this okay let's go
what what I headed door unlock itself
what the hell I don't like - yeah it's
just no good dog yes Oh what the hell
uh-huh well how'd it go down here ah yes
love is a beautiful thing I guess they
were wrong it's not are they turning to
dust - this is a really weird custom
story and much Mara yeah it is pretty
doctor oh okay okay you're coming with
us
crazy yeah yeah alright just keep going
I suppose our damn wall looks are good
okay you're right Dan that was uh uh
they're shut bricks okay it's not really
that scary yeah it's creepy atmosphere
though
it feels something Bad's gonna happen
Oh God okay stop making sad plays ah
operation not funny stop walking please
stop stop whatever your day yeah it's
not funny huh oh my god Bob what are you
doing ah it's not sexy okay was that huh
please stop no indoors no more doors I'm
not the Hulk I'm am freakin flexi button
okay we're good ah stop exploding stupid
duck why do you keep walking okay this
is not funny anymore this is not funny
anymore
[Applause]
no you can't don't put it in try hey bug
it's polenta well alright Amy oh hello
Betty
I'm your dick you but I want a dad again
I don't let her get certified
besides not bad I gotta give your took
you're too far away I mean close oh no
no the glutes stefana I'm sorry sir
Potter it's okay Polly lovely lady out
there I got em bad
you know she look she can't be French
girl she has to be a time I know all
right what the hell
hey listen D I can't touch him why and
they glued him for whatever reason uh
yeah what that right so many so many
yeah but the carpet you can take the
carpet but not I am disappointed uh
whatever maybe he's sick of my Stefano
the one who's mad that guy's gonna
stroll him
hey watch I can't actually watch either
here oh I hate that [ __ ]
aw snap it's gonna burn me
so sing again forgive me for making this
it was short I don't know I liked it was
a lot of that I won't see him making
we're painting out I don't remember that
okay yeah but we don't know how that
much time today anyway so I think it was
good
okay okay
in brofist okay maja yes please save me
anyone would they go back I need you way
she went you [ __ ] need her ah
Salomon never guy but all of your nipple
guys all of you one by one you apart